[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when I some was like I was seeing a
ghost like every trigger I've ever
pulled
how'd he start you hunting birds rabbit
I guess in nineteen twenty years old the
first time he ordered you to shoot a
person
25 years ago he took my blood
made you from me
has been lying to you the whole time
told you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best and just trying to rattle
me trying to save you
[Applause]
you made a choice to do this to me the
whole point of this thing was to give
you all of Henry's gifts without his
pain I don't want to shoot you mind if I
shoot you
Henry is this ever having you before
your own government trying to kill you
that's new
everything that we've worked for is at
stake
[Music]
he has to die is your darkness you had
to walk through this on your own I love
you Junior
we created
or the inspiration for office when I
just make a whole army full of it
why not you should be flattered you
should be dead
this has to be stopped
because what if somebody actually know
what we really are
[Music]